The ability to choose.
In fact, so many questions about why things happen are answered with just simply
humanity's ability to make a choice.
And choices really are what governs so much of our lives from the easiest decisions
to some of the hardest to choices that take forever to make
and ones that we make in an instant.
And it's choices that are so powerful, and they're a privilege, and
they're a responsibility, and it's something that God has given us.
And this is one of those, again, one of those pointers to who God is and the fact
that he exists. But here's the key question.
How do students' choices—how do all of our choices,
actually—reflect God? How do the things that we choose, whether it be right,
whether it be wrong, good, bad, ugly, whatever it is, how do those choices reflect
God? Some of our choices obviously do.
A lot of our choices obviously don't.
But when we talk about our ability to choose and the fact that God gave it to us,
there's some things we really have to make sure we nail down with our students.
So we're challenging students with two things.
Number one, that our free will points us to him.
The fact that we have free will is a pointer to who he is.
It helps us understand that because we have the ability to choose, that God is out
there somewhere. But number two, our free will should reflect him.
And how we behave as Christians ought to be a reflection of who he is.
So as you go about your unit this week, I want you to keep something in mind.
Last week we took a temperature of our students to figure out where the students
are. This week I want you to take temperature of your community.
Now we talked at the very beginning about the importance of establishing a
community, a strong community, a community that is open, one that loves, one that's
close, one that students feel safe in.
We talked about that kind of being an overarching goal of being able to communicate
truth and love is to have a community where students feel safe to ask questions and
so forth. So how is that community doing, right?
How is it working? Are there adjustments that you need to make?
It's so easy, especially as a leader of large groups to figure out, okay, how are
all these groups working? Is there other issues or they're not?
Does everybody feel like they belong?
Even if you only do a small group yourself, it's really easy to get caught up and
forget about maybe one particular student that has a ton of really great things to
say but for some reason doesn't feel like they can say those things.
So it's good to take a step back, take a look at our communities and see are we
hitting the mark about where we want to be?
So a couple things I want you to think about.
Are leaders providing the right atmosphere?
Are they crafting that sort of atmosphere of discussion when the questions are
welcome one of grace and love but with truth and not letting one student
dominate, inviting all students to participate.
All of those pieces of the puzzle is the right kind of atmosphere being fostered.
Number two, are students being loved and are they being challenged?
So often we kind of confuse the two and we think that if we're loving students and
we're just kind of letting them think what they want to think and we're, you know,
in my experience, the most challenged students that I had in
terms of how much I challenged them were the ones that felt most loved at the
end of a year. Those are the ones that, you know, felt like they were valued.
Go to any school in any classroom where in the middle of things students
are frustrated, they're under pressure, and they think a teacher
or somebody is really too hard on them and they complain about it.
If you notice, go back to those schools and ask those teachers how many graduates
come back to see them and the number's probably pretty high
the more so it sort of works this way the more challenging you are with a student
the greater respect you gain and the greater love that you are showing them it
just works that way so make sure that you love them but make sure you also challenge
them Number three, do they feel safe to be honest?
I mean if we're loving them properly then that's probably going to be the case that
they do feel safe. But there are some things that you know we want students to be
honest but sometimes their honesty causes us to have to react in a way that they
don't want us to react. But do they feel safe?
Do they feel like they can be honest with us and then we're gonna react
appropriately?
Number four, are your small groups serving one another.
Are you guys in your small groups caring for one another?
Have you created a community where you love each other, where the students are
loving on each other? It isn't just a place where you kind of come together, say a
few things, and then off you go into something else and off to your real friends or
whatever the case is.
Are your small groups becoming a tight-knit community of people who care and love
for one another? Now I would encourage you as a next step for that is to take those
and get those students out into the community, whether it be the wider community or
even just the church community, and find places for them to serve together and do
things together to help build and foster that kind of community.
All right, so you've almost made it to the halfway point.
Congratulations. Keep it up. You guys are doing a great job, I am sure.
And remember, some of your students might be starting to feel some of the stress of
school because you're probably getting around midterms and finals and tests and
quizzes and those kinds of things.
So now would be a really good time, and this is a really good lesson to do some fun
things, to have some fun with students on making choices, whether it be through
games, whether it be through examples, something silly, but you could have a whole
bunch of fun having students make choices, but at the same time teach them the power
of those choices.